This is Hudson, as you can see he’s pretty excited about being at the beach today.
However, there is a bylaw in place for how the beaches in the Waimakariri are used
and it includes some pretty key rules for us dog owners.
Dogs are welcome at most beaches in the Waimakariri
however they’re not allowed around the Ashley-Rakahuri Estuary and Wetlands
that’s to safeguard the local bird habitat.
Dogs also aren’t allowed between the surf flags or within 50 metres of the flags.
And around horses on the beach, dogs must be under effective control
If they can’t be controlled by your voice then they must be put on a leash.
So that’s it in a nutshell, it’s really simple
and as always make sure you bring plenty of these to clean up after your furry friend.
We’ve all got a part to play in preserving our beaches and estuary.